without Abraham Lincoln and really his
beard Milton Bradley the godfather of
board games would have never existed
bold statement I know but let me explain
the game of life the spinner the cars
the choices college or career kids or no
kids lawyer or farmer this family game
night staple was once a pretty morbid
game back in the 1800s Milton Bradley
was in the lithograph business following
the Republican National Convention of
1860 Bradley printed thousands of images
of Abraham Lincoln who was clean-shaven
at the time shortly thereafter Lincoln
debuted his iconic beard rendering all
of Bradley's prints worthless his lift
the graph business went belly-up
so Bradley was forced to try something
new he came up with a board game a
seemingly dark and twisted board game
appropriately named the checkered game
of life the game functioned in a similar
way to how it does now
there was a spinner colored circles that
moved around the board and of course
squares that could either make you or
break you the squares on the original
game were overwhelmingly grim boasting
actions like disgrace poverty ruin crime
prison and well suicide regardless the
game flew off the shelves kids loved it
and Milton Bradley went on to own family
game night fast forward to about a
hundred years later they revamped the
game trading Bradley's morbid squares
for the more delightful ones like pay
day or graduation which we have all come
to know and love and so there you have
it the story of the game called life
thanks Lincoln